well you've been watching the murder
trial of kyle rittenhouse this is
closing arguments day it has taken all
day um they're obviously being very
detail-oriented um the jury is listening
to all of this and is expected to get
the case tonight um we're gonna we're in
a 10-minute break in the trial so we'll
take it around the table here katie
pelvic chest guitar love jessie waters
and greg gutfeld are all here for the
five
he said not to talk about the case
what would you rather talk about i don't
know i mean i don't wanna you know i
hate to get in trouble yes i don't want
to get in trouble i don't want to do
anything that would be wrong um jesse uh
get your opening
argument your opening statement
i love that you can see in this country
the wheels of justice turn like this
there's not other countries that you can
just watch a live trial see all the
evidence see the testimony in the video
there's really no reason if this looks
like it's going the way it's going for
anybody to be violent if you've watched
this case closely
kyle was there trying to help the
community the people that were shot were
there to harm the community kyle did not
have a criminal history of these people
did have a criminal history
kyle gave up his body armor the defense
counsel made a great point why would you
give up your body armor if you were some
sort of active shooter looking for
trouble and they searched kyle's phone i
didn't even realize that they searched
and seized his phone he didn't have
anything in there about militias white
supremacy the phone was clean but the
one guy's phone they had a subpoena for
they didn't search the one guy changed
his case about three times and is a
stone cold liar the antifa medic this
guy rosenbaum the convicted pedophile
who was chasing him using the n-word at
a blm rally do you really think he was
with that crowd if he's using the n-word
at a blm rally he's chasing him down
he's physically grabbing the weapon and
then again assaulted with a skateboard
kicked in the head punched and then he's
got a loaded glock aimed at him this
whole time kyle's on the ground so the
case is cut and dry and the prosecution
knows they indicted too early they know
they overcharged so what do they do they
lie they get up on clothes today and
they say
yeah uh he shot rosenbaum in the back no
he didn't they had expert witnesses
testify didn't shoot him in the back and
then remember he got caught coaching
that one witness to lie and says you
don't have the right to self-defense if
you're the one that brings the weapon
straight up not true and then he says
he's an active shooter and you're
watching video that is clear as day this
guy had ample opportunity to cap anybody
and katie and i were in the break
talking about he had 30 rounds
the democrats won't what do they want 10
tops if he had had less than 30 he he
might not have survived that night so
it's a political case the guy says out
there defense counsel he wants to nail
kyle's hide to the wall because he needs
a scapegoat for the violence in kenosha
think about it
the whole city burned down and the guy
that went in to protect the city from
burning he's now supposed to rot in jail
for the rest of his life it's
preposterous if you don't if you don't
like the system leave all right the
judge appointed by a democrat appointed
by a democrat and then ran for
reelection the people put him there the
jury half of them were selected by the
prosecution you have a problem with that
go live somewhere else okay
this is a great system of government we
have it is extremely transparent
we expect justice he was allowed to have
that ar-15 as a 17 year old that night
this is as clear a cut a case as
self-defense i have ever seen and katie
you are in particular knew a lot about
the weapons charges here
so the the question that we were
discussing uh during the trial is why
did the judge drop the the dangerous
weapons charge and the defense which has
been very good for kyle uh read the law
and brought it to the judge and said
you're allowed to have a rifle so long
as it is not a short barreled rifle and
the rifle the ar-15 that kyle
rittenhouse had that night was not a
short barrelled rifle and therefore he
was legally allowed to possess that
weapon they throw out the dangerous
weapons charge and now the prosecution
has practically no nothing to go on at
this point um i want to talk about um
you know how the the defense has gone
back to the evidence in this maybe we
can get to this to the defense attorney
uh
which number thought number two uh
there's a call for number two control
room if you could pull that one up and
tom um thomas binger um basically is the
he's the prosecutor and the defense is
talking about him lying here watch this
think back to back on november 2nd when
this case started
did you hear one
word out of mr binger's mouth about
provocation
you didn't because it was never said
but when his case
explodes in his face
now he comes out with provocation
one he's lying
two he's misrepresenting
or
he wasn't prepared when he started this
trial and his closing argument has been
a change to try and fit what has come up
katie
so the defense has been able to go back
to the evidence with the jury to show
them to let them see what happened
whereas the prosecution has repeatedly
changed their story based on their own
witnesses blowing their their case gage
gross groice for example admitting that
he was fired upon by kyle rittenhouse
after he pointed his glock 19 in his
face and so therefore proved the
self-defense case for the jury one thing
that's happening in kenosha right now
there's been a lot of public opinion
about this kyle was tried in the court
of public opinion there are national
guard troops on guard to make sure that
the place isn't burned down again
watching all the footage and watching
the evidence from this trial brings up
last summer again and how this was
allowed in city after city
completely you know buildings burned to
the ground private business people were
killed as a result of this rioting and
it was excused over and over and over
again and tonight people are threatening
to riot if kyle is not convicted well
who are they defending in this case are
they defending uh
rosenbaum who is a convicted sex
offender child rapist are they defending
uh the uh huber who was a domestic
abuser who was charged with felony
strangulation is that what we're doing
here because then it really points out
right versus wrong in this country and
are you on the side of kyle rittenhouse
who was there to clean up graffiti and
defend his his community or are you
going to defend the guys who ended up
you know attacking him this band of
criminals who attacked him in the street
is that who you're going to defend and
burn the city down again for i mean
that's that's what this comes down to at
this point in the threats that are being
made there are 500 national guard troops
that were ordered to the area in
anticipation of the verdict yeah i mean
you have the media of saying we're
bracing for riots but they're pretending
to be ignorant of their role in setting
this all up and they're telegraphing at
it as always that somehow it is
acceptable to to riot or wage some kind
of violence in the streets because there
is no justice and you have to take a
time machine and go back and remind
people about jacob blake right a
knife-wielding brute who attempted to
kidnap
an
her kids she called the police and the
police came and did their job they shot
him that was their job he had a knife
yet the media in collusion with the
activist class you know greenlit the
violence like you said and the riots and
um that later exposed this void where
there was no law enforcement when that
happens you end up with citizens and and
the second amendment coming together to
fill that vote
void but it goes back to we've been
covering this stuff for like almost
seven eight years there's a bigger
problem these are parts of the problem
the bigger problem is the the refusal to
look at the handful of deadly outcomes
between police and suspects as
individual cases right we can count them
it's really easy there's maybe 20 to 30
a year
any journalist could spend an hour a day
and figure out how each one is different
if you actually looked at these 25 or 30
cases more than half are are white if
you did that you wouldn't be able to
have riots
because you'd see that each one is
different for example if you looked at
jacob blake individually you never would
have had these riots you would have seen
he was a knife-wielding
feed but what you have now and what
we've we've fallen prey to is everything
is grouped under one heading all these
cases fall under systemic racism created
by police brutality in a system that
doesn't allow for justice for blacks
creates this whole this this narrative
of hopelessness and rage there's no
justice no equality no opportunity and
that replaces achievement with angst and
which and what it really is is if you
just took the
damn time and looked at each case
you would see
that all of this pain and suffering is
unnecessary
if you could pull up call for number one
for us this is the prosecutor binger on
self-defense we mention this briefly but
i think it's worth playing this again
they have to convince you that joseph
rosenbaum was going to take that gun and
use it on the defendant because they
know
you can't claim self-defense
against an unarmed man like this
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one who brought the gun when
you're the one creating the damn danger
when you're the one provoking other
people jessica we haven't had your
thoughts yet but i thought you know that
was something that a lot of people are
like wait what how how could that be
yeah blue checkmark twitter was even
like
i mean i joked with them in the break
like even i know that's not right and
i'm no gun expert uh
i think the prosecution has not done a
great job and
putting aside even inconsistencies in
the story as we've gone from november
2nd up until today there just been have
a a few comments that have come out that
have raised eyebrows like do you know
this case well enough do you know the
laws in wisconsin well enough because
there's obviously a very specific set of
laws especially governing self-defense
and guns that this prosecutor seems to
not be aware of and when the judge
dropped the gun charge earlier this
morning i was like okay this is done
right because everybody had kind of
assumed this was the only thing that he
was possibly going to be held on the
possession of a dangerous firearm and we
were talking also about whether we think
there will be these riots tonight and
how hopeful we were that it wouldn't or
tomorrow night whenever the verdict may
come back if it is that he's acquitted
that maybe we can move past this and to
greg's point about people not knowing
the details of things
where you go for your source material
matters so much because there are a lot
of people
it's not your fault necessarily that you
didn't know that the two people who
passed away and this were not black it
was not advertised for a very long time
that the victims were white or i should
say three victims two dead one injured
and
to your point about you know are you on
the side of a convicted pedophile to me
that doesn't matter i understand in the
grand scheme of things that is someone
who i don't want to know versus i would
like to know you and you know continue
to be friends these those things aren't
comparable but it doesn't mean a death
sentence for someone because they did
something and i think we need to move
away from that because this idea of
vigilantism is so dangerous and it's
being used in so many different ways you
know the justice system as jesse said it
plays out and it does its job and
rosenbaum had whatever is coming to him
he's been convicted of it already
let that happen but no one deserves to
die
in that particular instance because of
something that happened before
not just but it goes to his character
and the idea that he was more than
willing to be there he was rioting he
attacked kyle rittenhouse and said he
was going to kill him he had dangerous
weapons like chains previously in the
night so you know character matters and
your your history matters and
we've tried this case in the court of
public opinion and i think it's really
important that people understand who
these people are in terms of their
character especially since people like
the president of the united states
smeared kyle rittenhouse as a white
supremacist who was just a vigilante in
this community when really he was there
trying to give medically cleaning up his
community taking you know he was asked
to be there to protect people's property
and to protect people's lives quite
frankly and so if we're going to try
kyle in the court of public opinion i
think it's more than fair to try the
people who attacked him violently in the
street and to talk about their criminal
records as well which includes raping
small children but you do obviously it's
terrible and i don't want to be the girl
that's just defending a pedophile on
national television but you do know
jesse
but you do get into conversations then
with how many people came out talking
about george floyd like what drugs he
was on how many priorities well yeah i
would have to talk about that if people
hadn't convicted kyle rittenhouse or
even at the beginning of this case if
there had been
accurate and folsom reporting about
jacob blake in the front in the first
place i i i want to have you call up uh
number seven but before that jesse did
you want to comment on the self-defense
well it goes to
if someone is a suicidal bipolar maniac
off his meds yelling the n-word and i'm
gonna f you up lunging at a weapon and
chasing this guy
that package has to be
demonstrated to the jury and it was and
if you would evaluate a problem like
this you would want your defense counsel
to make that exact argument so last week
when the trial was underway kyle
rittenhouse did break down on the stand
here is what the prosecutor said about
that this is as the jury is about to go
to deliberate
one of the first things that they saw
was on that first day kyle rittenhouse
and his emotion this is how the
prosecutor described it
even on the witness stand when he
testified on wednesday
he broke down crying about himself
not about anybody that he hurt that
night
no
remorse no concern for anyone else
i don't know what the jury's going to
decide greg but i have to imagine that
like the prosecutor doesn't know that
yeah this guy is in way over his head he
he
he he reminds me of me when i'm not
prepared for this show
so it's like you just say things and
it's just like you know if he j you know
what he's trying
so hard not to do his job it would have
just been easier if he tried to do his
job but everything that he's been doing
so far has been so off the mark it's
clear that he just like
he's a terrible student he's like
somebody who slept in missed his classes
and just said maybe i could wing this so
this is also some people think he was
actually angling for a mistrial because
of the way he acted earlier last week
and when he holded held the gun the ar
yes i mean obviously it's not loaded but
i mean after alec baldwin do you know
for sure
and he pointed it at the jury
and his finger was on the trigger
like on the trigger
now the jury's already probably getting
death threats getting photographs taken
of them going into
the courtroom maybe somewhere else and
you think you want the prosecutor
pointing a weapon at you after the the
deadly accident at rust look at that
look at that right there he's pointing
that at the jury and this guy
is the state's lead prosecutor which is
crazy and then he puts out this video
which they worked days on to show that
kyle at one point had raised his weapon
never raised his weapon they ne he'd
never raised his weapon and they made
this huge showing of oh he raised his
weapon it just wasn't true yeah my
favorite part was when he today tried to
compare
this to a bar fight and then he turns to
the jury and goes you've all probably
been in a bar fight before yeah let's
play that actually
call for number three who hasn't
let's assume for a minute yeah
joseph rosenbaum is chasing after the
defendant because he wants to
do some physical harm to him he's an
unarmed man
this is a bar fight this is a fist fight
this is a fight that maybe many of you
have been involved in two people
hand-to-hand we're throwing punches
we're pushing we're shoving or whatever
but what you don't do is you don't bring
a gun to a fistfight katie
all right so uh the idea that he turned
to the jury and essentially said you're
just like the people that we're talking
about in this trial it's probably pretty
insulting to them the other thing is he
says he was an unarmed man well if we're
taking this case and looking at the
evidence according to fbi statistics
more people are killed each year with
hands with fists than people are killed
with ar-15s this idea that you could be
an unarmed person and not be dangerous
and also if you have a skateboard and
you're threatened to hurt someone with
it you can kill somebody with the
skateboards this idea that someone was
unarmed
and therefore they weren't a threat was
completely destroyed by all the evidence
that people saw throughout the trial you
wanted to comment because you hadn't
seen that they actually put up that
photograph yeah i couldn't believe that
was real that's just a roadhouse i mean
that's a classic maybe not the best
prosecutor maybe one element initially
he wanted to go with dirty dancing yeah
adding movie clips can sometimes be
helpful
to me
i also wanted to play if you would call
for number five um because
does the prosecutor have a point here
watch
the same set of rules
apply to the defendant as everybody else
there's no exception in the law for kyle
rittenhouse
there's no exception that says if anyone
else has a gun you're a danger except
for kyle rittenhouse
there's no exception in the law that
says
if you point your gun at people oh that
makes you a threat and i can kill you
except for kyle rittenhouse i can do it
all night long
the same rules apply to him as everyone
else hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else